did you recently get married I did we
are we're getting a divorce
breaking news right here it's not going
through well she's honestly she's so
needy and she spends my money and she
doesn't text back quickly and honestly
the other day I saw her at 1 Oak with
what Scott's brother older brother I
don't have an older brother younger
brother your friend make of all of this
because it was his mom right Jason's mom
he's happy that I'm in the family now
and I can help take care of his children
we're my grandkids now I think everyone
was pretty happy about it to be honest
it was like it was like the best time
like all jokes aside it was so much fun
getting married we went to Hawaii we had
a honeymoon yeah I was abstinent so I
finally got laid and it was the entire
process was just beautiful because I
don't know I didn't write a lot of
people cuz they're super private but now
that it's out in the open before we get
the divorce maybe I have like a big big
party are you gonna have a divorce party
is that what you're insinuating
listen Meghan can I talk about the
divorce party no my publicists saying no
what did your friends make of this like
did you guys sign off on this so he can
fill you about this marriage I think
we're all pretty jealous cuz we all had
eyes on mrs. now or miss Dober misses
dobrik now boy mom I mean I thought it
was beautiful
two loving individuals coming together
can we talk about this matrimony how
nice is this outfit how many people I've
interviewed so far it's pretty earlier
like two or three right this is this is
probably the best I mean you got the
gold chain it's the best it's the best
it's for that you didn't mean that did
you I it's the best I'm insecure so good
you dress yourself this morning no I did
not we know what his relationship status
is so I got to put you guys in the hot
seat who is spoken for and who is not Oh
i-i've never even hugged a girl
the single yes I am spoken for have a
woman christen McAtee here she's here
somewhere I think she might have she
didn't come prepared for the pink carpet
so I am spoken for
Olivia O'Brien I feel like sometimes you
guys share so much but then you don't
share a lot about the relationship
sometimes what Wyatt why do you guys
keep that stuff more quiet than what you
normally have his girlfriend hates him
or loves him no honestly I just don't
want David to exploit anything and take
advantage diva does kind eyes and listen
no actually no mistake about this
trouble my last question is about a
different Olivia how is she doing have
you guys talked to her Olivia Jade yeah
I I hope she's doing great I mean we've
said this before we wish everybody the
best right so I mean I think you would
to it I think that's the that's the
answer for that that's the best I don't
have anything else to say I don't I only
met her once but I hope she's doing the
best 12 Hail Marys and she's doing great
1212 help me cut that out now she's
doing great
don't cut anything hole goes there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]